[Music]
welcome back
and i'm now delighted to be joined by
quasi cortang minister of state for
business
energy and clean growth to deliver the
keynote address of today's energy spawn
summit sponsored by national grid now
the quasi first of all thank you for
making time it isn't exactly
am a cam week over there in parliament
so thanks for
um taking time to join us today um we're
going to hear
uh for about 15 minutes from quasi to
give us his perspective on green energy
in the uk and perhaps
some hints of the government's ambitions
and perhaps also time frame when we're
going to be getting back to this
agenda then i'll put some of my own
questions to the minister and
yours too so if you have any questions
then
please email us via the text box on zoom
or you can email events at spectacular
dot co dot
uk quasi quarten over to you thank you
very much
uh fraser it's a real pleasure uh
to be giving the keynote speech at your
event and national grids event national
grid obviously a company
i know well uh in my role and i'm
delighted to be able to take part
today in this forum um as you know
uh we've been under a huge amount of
pressure here in the uk and also in
other countries
uh regarding uh covid19 and the
pressures the responses that we've had
to that
crisis but having said all of that
uh one thing has remained very clear to
me as energy minister
that our government uh remains deeply
committed
uh both uh domestically and also
internationally
uh to come to tackle uh climate change
to make sure that here in the uk we're
at the at the
front uh showing world leadership
on this question of uh reducing carbon
emissions and that's something which
uh we still remain very focused on
uh as we fight uh the kovid 19
pandemic really after uh
dealing with the pandemic we feel that
we should be
focusing our efforts on growing faster
and further while tackling climate
change
and we want essentially to build a more
sustainable
and greener economy here in the uk
i think we've demonstrated very clearly
that you can actually increase
economic output you can increase
people's opportunities economically
while also
reducing carbon emissions indeed
since 1990 we've managed to reduce
carbon emissions by 43 in the uk
and uh grow the economy at the same time
by three quarters now some people will
say
uh we export a lot of those carbon
emissions
and that while that may be true to some
degree absolutely in absolute terms
there is no doubt
we've reduced carbon emissions uh by
something like a third which is an
extraordinary
accomplishment and it's something that
we need to improve
upon but we have done it i think we've
got to continue
along that path and we've also got to
continue to embrace
uh the opportunities offered by techno
by technology
uh in order to reach a greener more
sustainable
future and some of those innovations uh
are occurring in energy storage uh
technologies we need to have
a more efficient a smart and flexible
electricity system um many people i
think in this audience
will have adopted that will have bought
electric vehicles
and clearly that's a way forward that's
a big
piece of innovation which is driving our
uh attempt uh to decarbonize the economy
and also um there are eco-friendly
buildings now
uh that are being developed so lots of
technology i think can be harnessed
uh to help us reach the net zero target
if you look at industry um in the uk
today
it accounts for something like 16 of all
greenhouse gas
er emissions and this makes a big
contribution not only to uh
um emissions but also obviously uh to
our economy so a big challenge
uh for us is to decarbonize uh to
decarbonize industry and i think
if we look at our industrial uh clusters
uh there's a real opportunity to
decarbonize
uh those clusters i'm thinking of places
uh in the humber
uh t side um south wales
um and we can maximize benefits and
drive down costs i think through
decarbonization
our mission one of our missions is to
establish the world's
first net zero carbon industrial cluster
by 2040
and at least one low carbon costa
by 2030. i think uh if we achieve this
it will really establish our reputation
and our
achievement at the forefront
of a global shift to glean uh growth
um we are developing uh green
manufacturing product products
we're developing uh technologies and i
think
um because of all this innovation
because of all this
um dynamism we are beginning to attract
a great deal of inward investment uh new
business and employment opportunities
um i've been struck by how as a british
energy minister
people from all over the world are
asking us questions about
how we move from coal how we transition
from coal
uh to renewables people are very
interested in
uh schemes like the green homes grant
that we
are pioneering uh this year and they're
also interested in how we
fully intend to decarbonize our industry
we're supporting the transformation of
foundation industries
such as steel glass ceramics and
chemicals
and we're providing a great deal of
support
up to 66 million pounds so far to
develop radical new technologies
and establish innovation centers of
excellence
in spring 2021 i'm very hopeful that we
will launch our industrial
decarbonization strategy and that will
set out
uh very clearly i hope how government
intends to work with industry
uh to decarbonize uh our industries
following the announcements this july we
now have the green homes grant
which is now up and running and under
the scheme
many of you will know that the
government is funding up to two-thirds
of the cost of home improvements uh for
over six hundred thousand homes
and for um vulnerable uh people people
uh more economically insecure uh there
is the opportunity to fund up to a
hundred percent
uh up to ten thousand pounds this uh
grant scheme
uh not only actually delivers on
decarbonization but it also
uh will support uh something like eighty
thousand jobs
in green uh construction
um the one aspect i think which many of
you will be interested in
uh in terms of the green uh revolution
is of course
uh the area of green finance um i think
there's a huge opportunity
in uh for london for britain uh to be a
leader
in uh green finance many of the bankers
uh that speak to bayes that speak to me
are
um very interested in driving products
uh for an international market
i'm very hopeful that ahead of cop 26
later
uh next year we will be able to launch
uh green sovereign bonds
clearly that's something that's uh being
discussed but there again there are huge
opportunities i think
um in green um at the moment
uh the treasury is holding a review into
how the transition to a net zero
economy can be funded and where the
costs will fall
so again i think finance the prospect of
green finance
is something which we're all across
government
looking at very closely of course
one of the things that we are very
focused on as a government
is the leveling up agenda in october
this year i was delighted to see that
the prime minister announced
160 million pounds uh for the upgrade
of ports and for infrastructure which
can support
the uk in being a world leader in clean
wind
energy there's also the commitment that
was
uh first uh launched in the manifesto
last year
to produce 40 gigawatts of electricity
from offshore wind
by 2030 and uh there was also
a concomitant um commitment
uh to produce one gigawatt of offshore
wind
uh floating offshore wind by 2030. so 40
gigawatts of offshore wind
and one gigawatt of floating offshore
wind uh by 2030 and we hope
uh that we can use a cfd the contract
for difference
uh auction uh to achieve this
i think that um the growth and the
rollout of offshore wind capacity
will certainly benefit uh places in the
uk
uh such as grimsby a traditional fishing
port
um which has struggled in the past with
slowing demand
uh in that industry um but i think can
once again
uh thrive uh through developments
uh in the offshore wind uh sector
i think that the uh prime minister's
announcement was really a
first step um in the prime minister's
10-point plan
for what we're beginning to call a green
industrial revolution
and i'm hopeful that this uh 10-point
plan will be launched
by the prime minister later in the year
the 10-point plan will include ambitious
targets
and a major investment announcement of
major investment
in key industries which can i think
ultimately help us uh along the path
uh to net zero by 2050.
many of you i'm sure are waiting with
the eager anticipation
uh for the energy white paper i'm fully
uh expecting that that will come out
very shortly and that too will include
uh ambitious plans to decarbonize key
sectors
uh such as heating such as heating
and buildings and also it will look at
how we can
uh build um a more sustainable economy
more broadly i think we're going to
continue uh
to build uh on the successes that we've
had
it's been a very difficult time i think
uh particularly dealing with
covid19 while at the same time keeping
our eyes
very focused on building back
uh in a more green in a more sustainable
way
the government ahead of cop26 in
november next year
will continue to set out further
measures
as part of our green agenda i think it's
a very very exciting space there's
clearly a lot uh happening
and it's very much uh my pleasure my
uh a privilege really to be an energy
minister at such a dynamic and exciting
time
thank you very much thank you quasi well
it certainly is
a dynamic time in all the um the much
delayed
tory green agenda we every sort of
every few months the future starts
looking a little bit different my first
question is that you say
that in spring next year we're going to
have your industrial decarbonization
agenda now
normally these agendas are informed as
all energy policies
are informed by um trajectories
imagining what economic growth is going
to be like how energy intensive that
growth is going to be
how things going to look in three to
five years i imagine that particular map
is being redrawn quite a lot so right
now we've got no idea
what the economy is going to look like
in january let alone
in five years time so i'm wondering to
what extent
the the longer term forecasts that will
inform
your decarbonization agenda are in flux
right now and
how much your policy might be modified
by not so much the event of the last few
months but on people's changing
perceptions of what
the future of economic growth is going
to look like
i i actually think that there are two
things that one has to distinguish here
obviously
nobody knows exactly what the global
economy will do over the next month two
months
or even 18 months but there's clearly a
strategic
objective which is in many ways even
more important
and there's a global commitment to
decarbonization
now some people say well you know it's
all going to be very costly
um but what struck me over the last 18
months really the last 15 months that
i've been doing my job
is the degree of international consensus
around the need
to decarbonize i mean when president
xi's china
uh only a few weeks ago it's committing
itself
to net zero by 2060
um you can see there's been a real sea
change in
in global uh focus on this uh there's no
reason why china needed to make that
commitment
um many people used to say to me well
doesn't make any difference what we do
if the chinese aren't uh playing bull
and i'm pleased to say that they are so
uh
as a direct answer to your question i
don't think
that um the plans the immediate
forecasts
for the next year or two really bear
that much relevance
to a net zero commitment in 30 years
time i think you can disaggregate
uh both of those uh both of those
phenomena if you like there's the near
term uh fluctuations of the economy
and there's a longer term strategic uh
focus
on reducing carbon emissions i think
that the two are quite distinct
the first audience question is from
nigel freeman the
green homes grantee says it's a good
initiative but it needs to continue for
longer
i guess also the thing is when we're
coming out a lot of people are going to
be spending a lot more time
in their homes over the next few months
with the government's new
stereotype structures and is this
something which you
you might think well people are going to
be investing more in their home because
we might be living in an era
where we could be receiving stay-at-home
orders at any point
can you see this um perhaps being
extended
maybe this is a way of trying to stoke
the recovery as well
just help extending the help which you
give to people who wants to do up their
homes especially if you're going to be
spending
a lot more time working in these homes
as the home working phenomenon
continues after the pandemic it's a very
good question that but i mean
what i would say is that the green homes
ground is just part
of a wider manifesto commitment uh to
helping
our people uh decarbonize uh in their
homes
uh and make their homes more energy
efficient so
um the greenhouse grant is not the the
the be all and end all
of uh the government's commitment in
this area
i don't know what will happen uh to the
to the
this specific scheme but what i can say
is that
you know there is a massive ongoing
commitment as on the part of government
to try and drive this agenda and to try
and increase the carbonization of heat
in homes and to make those homes more
energy efficient and
uh you know anyone who's looked at our
manifesto i know people don't read
manifesto as much these days but
um we there are there are extensive
commitments fiscal commitments i think
up to about 9.2 billion pounds
in that manifesto across this parliament
to
to driving this agenda so the greenhouse
grant i don't know what its fate will be
but what i can say is that there will be
um prolonged uh
sustained commitment uh to to doing what
the green homes grant is trying to
promote which is
decarbonization in in homes and
buildings
and also uh to make those those
buildings and homes more energy
efficient
okay another question from and chris who
says
you talk about decarbonizing homes but
what about the heating of rural homes
that's a lot harder and and politically
more difficult for the government if
it's going to be
um asking people who use you know it's
not
methods of heating which are a lot
harder to modernize a lot more expensive
to modernize
is that um in the box marked too
difficult
it's not it's only the i mean you know
many of the people who are applying and
i see figures on a daily basis many of
the people who apply for the greenhouse
grant
uh they're not living in in you know
densely populated cities a lot of them
and there's a lot of interest in the
green homes grant across the country
and principally in rural areas i mean i
speak to mps from herefordshire
devon cornwall these aren't great urban
centers yet they are very very
interested in
the green homes crowd they're very very
interested in um you know the technology
adopting technology that um
can decarbonize and also um they're
interested in
retrofitting their own homes uh to make
them more energy efficient
and clearly the technologies for you
know a farm or a
a rural uh cottage if you like in uh
herefordshire
the heating demands are going to be
slightly different from a block of flats
in london
but i think there's there's equal
interest um across the country
in uh in in decarbonization and in in
making their homes more efficient energy
efficient because ultimately
more energy efficient homes will reduce
the cost and
across the country realize that a
question now from
martin franks and pretty soon he says
the government is going to be
facing a fiscal crisis the amount of
money that's borrowed to get us through
the pandemic
has been eye-watering and sooner or
later
the bank of england might stop printing
money the government rates might go and
you might be looking at some very hard
fiscal choices
so how confident are you that the
government's green agenda which is quite
expensive in many ways
will survive the coming budget cuts
we've got
several things i guess the point of the
question several things that seemed
affordable
this time last year might not be
affordable in the spring
um what do you have any feeling as to
whether
your own financial wings might be
clipped in this regard no i don't think
so at all i mean one of the things
that we've learned over the last year is
the rule of law we've said uh
well we always knew about the rule of
law but the rule of law has often
been uh cited as something that we take
very seriously in this country
and i have to emphasize that we
legislated four net zero
uh so whether um we like it or not there
is a legal commitment
uh to net zero carbon emissions in this
country by 2050
and there's no government uh under
whatever i think fiscal circumstances
that can ignore that i think we do have
a legal commitment to this
and i can see the agenda uh this
particular agenda
being adopted um and maintained
um on the governments of whatever
political strife i think it's something
that
about which there is a degree of bypass
and support and i think
i think there will be stresses on on our
fiscal
position um but i think we will have to
accommodate
uh a net zero serious net zero
commitment as well it is after all the
rule of the land
the law of the land a question from
karen mccloy and the prime minister
seems very interested
in hydrogen power the subject of his
speech recently is this an area of
growing focus
for the governments and even though
hydrogen is relatively
marginal player right now in transport
and
is this something which the government
is and rapidly getting more interested
in
we're very focused on this i mean i was
um made
energy minister in july last year july
2019 which in many instances
seems like a very very long time ago and
to some people will seem very recent
but one of the things i can say is that
the hydrogen agenda has shot up
uh people's priority list i mean
hydrogen is something that i think about
all the time
as an energyness and we think about how
we use it um the
potential usage in transport potential
usage um
in empowering decarbonization in
industry
um there are experiments in keele
university about blending hydrogen into
natural gas
so there are potentially lots of uses of
hydrogen and one of the things
one of the problems that we have to
solve is how
cheaply uh to produce uh decarbonized
hydrogen i mean i say decarbonize
because
one of the ways you produce hydrogen is
through what's called methane
reformation
and one of the offshoots of methane
reformation is carbon dioxide we need to
capture that
and many of you will have heard of
carbon capture uh usages
and storage cc us and one of the
byproducts of csus of course is
hydrogen which we call blue hydrogen
because it's been
decarbonized and of course there's a
whole
way of producing hydrogen through
electrolysis which is called
green nitrogen the products of which is
called green hydrogen which again we're
looking at
and all this will be outlined in the
hydrogen strategy which i hope will come
out
in the first quarter of next year um and
then
once our strategies comes that comes out
we will be looking at delivering
these projects so the next 18 months i
think will be
crucial to the development of a hydrogen
economy
it's funny you quite rightly say that
hydrogen shoots up the agenda
but isn't that the nature of the green
energy agenda
right now it's pretty difficult to sit
here in 2020 and think how this is going
to be in 2025
when it's removing so rapidly when
technologies like hydrogen that didn't
seem viable
only a couple of years ago suddenly
seemed more so now
and i'd like to bring in a question
again from nigel freeman saying what
about things like
um tidal power and will the government
be doing research and development
in that because who knows by about five
years time we may be talking about that
the green agenda does seem to surprise
us quite
you talk about it as if it's some sort
of act of god i mean people have decided
that that's what we want to do
it wasn't something that has just
evolved like you know from adam smith's
invisible hand i mean there's
been policy decisions that have made
these things happen
um you know when i came in uh to the
office at the beginning of this year
um after the christmas break i said to
my officials hydrogen is going to be a
big story let's
look at that and we've been looking at
it and we've been driving the agenda so
it's something that
we can control it's not something that's
happened to us
and i think uh and it was in nigel who
said about um
uh tidal power we absolutely need to
look at tidal power
many of the projects that i've seen i'm
afraid haven't been uh as cost-effective
as they might have been
but that's definitely something that
we're looking at and if we get
get it right we'll get the auction
process right we can incentivize
investment um we can we can score a
success
uh in that too i just wanted to resist
this idea that
somehow the green revolution is
happening um
as though it were an act of nature it's
no it's not it's something that
you know takes a lot of policy a lot of
business entrepreneurship
a lot of innovation a lot of research um
and it all comes together in sometimes
uh things
lead to a dead end but um a lot of the
time you know these things are are being
willed
uh in a deliberate uh in a deliberate
way and and it's a very exciting for
that reason
a very exciting area well quasi
courthousing is an incredibly busy day
in parliament so thank you
thank you very much for joining us and
we would
well let's put our invisible hands
together to give you a round of applause
thank you